oh then it was that it was Nintendo
obviously here we go let's go so the I
had another neighbor on the street and
he was uh a couple of years younger than
I but he got the Nintendo Entertainment
System he had rob you know remember the
robot yeah yeah we use it
he had he had the zapper before they
changed it and made it like uh uh orange
or something yeah and I remember like
just you know when Mario first booted up
and just that music kicked in just the
first time I jumped in and hit that
invisible block I was just I was hooked
it was just such a phenomenal experience
then eventually I cheated on Nintendo
let's talk about this fling let's talk
about this yeah let's talk about this I
wound up getting a Sega Genesis right oh
right
okay so the Nintendo part you didn't own
one per se
not initially